I rearranged things on the screen here a
little bit. just so I'd have room to write
my answer out, but this is all the
information that you had to start the last
quiz with. Remember, from our practice
using substitution before, that if we see
a variable in one equation, but we know
that that variable is = to some other
expression, then we can substitute in that
alternate expression in the place of the
original variable. So, in the case of w
and n, for example, we have these two
numbers that we can now replace them with.
So, we see w here, 402w, and w here, w = 30.
So I can take the 30, and move it into
this slot. And I can do the same thing
with n and 12. I'm going to rewrite this
side of the equation again, but this time
with our new numbers plugged in. In place
of w I put 30 and in place of n I put 12.
Now we need to recall our understanding of
order of operations. So PEMDAS. The thing
we need to decide here is whether we
multiply or we add first. Since we have we
have two terms that are multiplied and
another two terms that are multiplied but
then also an addition sign. In our past
practice with simplifying expressions we
always simplified within each term, or
multiplied everything out, before we
combined like terms or added, and that's
completely in line with PEMDAS. Remember,
this is an acronym to help you remember
the order in which you do different
mathematical operations within a given
expression. So the M here, which stands for
multiplication, comes before the A, which
stands for addition. So we're going to do
our multiplication first. 402 times 30 =
12,060, and 480 times 12 = 5,760. Last but not
least, we add these two numbers together.
This gives us a final answer of 17,820.
Much to the delight of Grant and his
venture capital funders. They're going to
bring in $17,820 with just the
orders that have been placed so far in the
first few weeks. That is really
incredible. Grant has proven that he has a
product, or actually two products, that are
popular and people think are really going
to be useful. He is convinced he's out to
change the world, or at least the way that
glasses wearers see the world.
Congratulations on great work, we covered
a ton of material, and I am sure that you
did great.